hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime up or your host of the
latest episode of rant cafe in this one
we're gonna be discussing the most
overrated anime of all time lots to talk
about this week by the way my computer
has been a little crazy so you know if I
randomly cut out or something like that
then you'll know why we're getting a new
one so hopefully in the next few weeks
it's gonna be a good one
well yeah welcome everyone again back
again for another week rant cafe like 57
or something I don't know anymore
featuring Knox Taku na ligado is back
all day Anna Mae Briggs is back and
still maka is back after mysteriously
disappearing last week no one knew what
he was doing where he was at but now
he's here yay yeah yeah yeah turn that
[ __ ] down break bad what's up guys yeah
I'm always thought I'm like another
person actually showing their face
otherwise it's just me and a bunch of
freakin cyber hiding people I'm sorry I
don't I gotta put my face on before I go
in front of the camera box they don't
walk around with faces unless people see
them I done by the way by the way guys
well we're gonna for this video what I
was thinking of like for the discussion
when we talk about overrated I don't
mean just bad anime necessarily like
anime that is bad but popular but even
anime that might be good but it just
wasn't as good as people made it out to
be all that kind of stuff right so we're
gonna be talking about that because
often and that's another whole topic
related to this Indiana made community
often people will talk up an anime so
much before you see it it's so popular
everyone's talking about it and even if
it's actually good you're thinking man I
was expecting some kind of masterpiece
the way people were talking about it and
it wasn't you know up to that so for
example I'll bring up good the now is
here because she was really talking
about ancient Magus bride hmm and Knox
completely even though I don't think he
thinks it's a bad show he completely
thinks it would be overrated in that
sense am I wrong no well
I actually um see this is my whole
entire out thing like I understand why
people can get bored I understand why
they can see why it's overrated like I
understand the other side now from from
episode 1 up until now I can understand
because now that I'm comparing this with
the manga I'm starting to get
disappointed is it just a slow pace
magnified one day it's not only the the
slow pace it's the reveal like when they
reveal stuff it's not as shocking and
the anime the fight scenes they don't
amp it up you know what I mean and among
that like the the fight scenes were
juicy the shocking scenes were shocking
like this is they're just presenting
stuff at a really really dull level and
I'm starting to get really pissed off
with it's just because that's sort of
what I've been saying since like episode
4 something I promise ok I promise that
the manga is way more exciting than the
anime I have I've never once insulted
the manga I don't believe while recons
not here so I don't have a comparison
but I don't believe in insulting things
I haven't experienced I prom yet like I
just I don't want the anime to like
deter people away from the manga I've
seen I've heard that argument before
many times in terms of like the manga
being better like for Tokyo ghoul people
are telling me man the manga is a lot
better I know for manga that I've read
attack on Titan my hero academia the
manga is much more fast paced a black
clover another great example of you know
an anime where people say that manga is
much better much more fast paced so I
totally understand that and now I your
concern about you being deterred from
the end manga is a good one not saying
that you know the anime itself is good
just because of the manga because
they're separate but people should
definitely not exclude a manga just
because they don't like the an anime or
the pacing of an anime we have a lot of
comments in the chat we had some
comments about kimi no na wa or your
name being overrated i disagree that
would be one of the animes / anime
movies that really lived up to the hype
for me like there was a lot of hype for
sure it was talked up a lot and then i
watched i was like yes this is worth the
hype
for me personally otherwise mentioned
Naruto and Dragon Ball super I would
disagree with this being overrated and
I'll tell you why
overrated doesn't just mean popular so
it's not like in my opinion so it's not
like saying if something is popular that
means it's overrated because for for me
for example from Dragon Ball super or
from Naruto I'm not expecting you know
like a masterpiece of storytelling I
know it's a battle Shonen it's an action
shown in while you're there for mostly
is the fights and the epic of battle
scenes so you know what to expect if
someone was talking broke Dragon Ball
super is as deep as full metal his
Brotherhood and all this kind of stuff
when I was a coach it really and I look
at it then I'm like yeah that was
overrated but I don't think anyone is
saying that so for that reason I
wouldn't call it overrated what about
you guys so I have to say that as far as
the battle Shonen goes if you're just
watching it for the cool fights and
whatever it's a pretty crappy battle
shown in one piece the action is garbage
no offense Briggs but the show's awesome
anyway yeah maybe with you know I can
agree with that I can agree with that i
think adam ak is he's just using it as
an example like he going for the action
like obviously you like you love the
characters and stuff like that and like
that story it's like you go there from
what it is yeah exactly
it depends what you're hoping to get out
of it for example when I was watching
Keijo I knew going in that it's like XE
comedy and that's kind of like
self-aware and stuff and I loved it
because of that but I wasn't expecting
it to be you know an amazing sports
anime or something like that you can if
I was I would definitely be disappointed
I was like this is so unrealistic and
stuff like that and a lot of people were
but that's not what I was expecting from
it that's why I would say that I enjoyed
it for what it was yeah for example with
yeah I got at that time bleach was still
big because it was just like SS Ark and
obviously new ozone and stuff like that
and I was into those anime at the time
and if
you recommended the Gintama to me said
or watch it is awesome is just like
bleach so first episode I watched that
first episode and it wasn't awesome it
was them running around after this fat
woman's cat and then getting caught up
and you know guy getting eaten by the
big bad cat thing whoever is okay no
dropped a game so firstly and most
importantly the first two episodes of
Gintama are actually filler what you
said yes especially because the series
is like 85% canon and they made the
first two episodes filler which is
pathetic and Gintama is even though no
one freakin watches it because there's
so many Japanese references never got a
dub but it's an amazing show okay
doesn't even deserve to be mentioned on
this on this stream however bleach and
they may eat me in the comments I think
bleach is the most overrated battle
Shonen no I wouldn't say that I wouldn't
say that because bleach actually got
ripped apart more so than the other of
the big free well it deserves a lot more
than the other again but yes I wouldn't
call it overweight because that one got
like that got wrecked by mangofox that
the bleach fans left they literally left
mangofox tomato on say dude teching is a
youtuber yeah he freaking loves bleach
he talks up bleach like crazy and he's
also really into one piece but he says
bleach is way better can you explain
something like that to me what no
because I'm in it there are with this
and really like bleach and while I think
that bleaches soul society art was great
it was like one of my favourite shounen
arts altogether like probably listen
we're not called professionals I mean
the difference the difference with one
piece the people
find like annoying is there's no drive
to the plot the we know they're going
for the one piece we don't we don't see
like progression getting because no no I
have not everyone is otherwise that
would never because line there's two
major things he has to become the Pirate
King and he also wants to get the one
piece unable to do that he has to
conquer the Grand Line in his own path
not necessarily not necessarily he's
trying to be Roger did is conquering the
Grand Line and then gaining the one
piece and doing that yes the conquer the
grand line first guys I'm surprised I
didn't start doing these guys and we not
debate the merits of one piece of story
every stream both sides blame knocks
next Knox boy up it's long actually I
actually wanted to mention your name
again and actually talk about why I
think it's overrated and I think yeah I
think it's because oh god Baca
one of my buddies he did a really good
review on it on why they're just kind of
feeding you eye candy the whole entire
time and kind of diverting away from
kind of like this melancholy kind of
like cliche story it's it's really well
done there the story is very cliche it's
very young I think I did like your name
I had issues with it too so maybe I
would say it's overrated cuz if everyone
gives it a 10 out of 10 I would still
only give it a 9 out of 10 for example
but that's I don't know it's if it's
that overrated Coen no katachi I
disliked I did not enjoy my experience
watching Coen no katachi at all I'm Kim
you know Noah sorry
kami no Noah yeah minion but I think it
was way overrated way over it but why
why would you say I was over it I didn't
like any I get like a single aspect to
the entire movie
yeah what's that what are you talking
about I'm sorry are you talking about
your name or Cory no katachi silent boys
yeah I liked it I actually really liked
it just because um kinda gave a
different feel like it was still cliche
but it gave a different feel with like
you know the girl having that kind of
disability by really it was a mess I
don't know for me it was a nice
character-driven story and you got to
face and see these flaws within these
characters they weren't there was no
perfect character everyone had their
flaws and there they had to basically
face up to or overcome their flaws to be
able to progress in their life within
this story that will give I know anime
dude liked koi no katachi everyone likes
gitaji except for me so I'm not I'm not
calling you crazy because you know
everyone seems to like it first a reason
but from my perspective you have a guy
who was a bully turned out not good for
him okay that's one guy that whatever it
was very cliche also everything that
happened you clearly saw happening from
a mile away yeah the girl that was deaf
you had a different girl who was a total
psycho and like no character to them at
all we maybe you didn't watch the same
thing or maybe you just didn't
understand it starts for different folks
I think he's more into something that's
fast faster pace because that was kind
of like a slower pace yeah more quicker
yeah and it was just my personal taste
because everyone else seems to like it
kind of like with me and no game no life
like I'm one of the people that doesn't
like it because I thought it was so
cliche and so many tropes just fan
pandering and it was one of those when I
was watching and I was wanting to like
it because a lot of people are talking
it up and the world they set up is kind
of cool but then I just so many jarring
like cliches were just hitting me in the
face and I was like man
why why I didn't think what was all that
great yeah all right so I'm not the only
one all right I know like our key
dearest loves that so many people loved
it but it was like am I saying I did let
me address some are not agreed with
everything nuts has said this entire
podcast I Love You Man oh yeah what a
lovely bromance you guys should ice
skate together um let me address some
comments from the chat yes gilgamesh say
free is stupid I've never seen free so I
can I can't say it was stupid Jay Sean
said guilty crown and I feel like guilty
crown was over rated at one I don't
think so anymore it's not that much
attack on Titan season 2 definitely not
over 800% word [ __ ] and worth the hype
but sacrifice season 2 was better than
season 1 it was [ __ ] amazing
one slow episode in season 2 the
animation was garbage
we know that's that's all right I don't
like animation arguments I watch anime
from the 70s from like Seoul when
someone's like oh the animations not
good I'm not that guy
like obviously I appreciate good
animation my people oh the animation was
not like no I I don't buy that I don't
for me it's about story and characters
and music that's perfectly good and then
all of a sudden you turn it into garbage
okay it's really adorable I believe you
don't think that animation is worth
anything but then we say why don't you
like Castlevania and you say oh they
have a pretty terrible so let's see well
no that's one part of it but it's not
that the animation itself was terrible
it's that the way they portrayed things
like faces was terrible and not sincere
so you mean it was like a problem with
the art style yes rather than the art
style is nothing to do with the story
man chill did your characters are
supposed to be emotional but their faces
are not betraying any emotion even
though they should to make the story
feel real then that's a problem
Castlevania another example of an
overrated not anime but still okay look
I
with your sentiment on Castlevania
completely but as far as Rico's rigs
overrated the [ __ ] out of cassoulet it
was [ __ ] great I don't care you guys
watch it like I dropped our first white
life Wow four wins offer and crap like
that SquarePants then you have no right
to complain about animation if anything
hold on I don't know if there's like a
delay or something guys let's try to
talk one at a time if anything attack on
titan season one had a bunch of episodes
that were slow whereas the taconite in
season two was awesome and just like
very much manga like in terms of the
pace kept me on the edge of my seat
every episode it was amazing again back
to some of the chat comments re0 was
mentioned and i feel this is right this
is true because while reezy row again it
is a good anime people talked it up so
much to me that I when I came into it
expecting so much and then I wasn't that
impressed which is a problem again when
people overhyped something with my hero
academia same thing a lot of people
mentioned mine your academia being
overrated and by the way Giga also says
academia like me not academia so I feel
better now but the point was this is I
wouldn't say my Turk name academia is a
bad anime at all the manga is even
better especially once it gets going
however it's so overhyped especially in
the YouTube community with people saying
look at this opening it's so brilliant
look at this song it's so pretty look at
every aspect every character is so
brilliant and genius and it's the next
Naruto one piece is the next everything
right it is so people do talk it up so
much that even if it's good it kind of
like it's hard to live up to those
expectations it's almost impossible
you guys brought out a proportion in it
but I mean I think that's how alone a
lot here sorry
corner my ear academia I think was
extremely overrated while I still liked
it I have to agree with you and to prove
that point to the anime man made a poll
and when he got like 600,000 votes
of anime and my here academia made the
second place for the best anime of all
time that's ridiculous
that's insane yeah that's them and
that's the problem when something is
fresh and current if you just check out
like the my enemy list in IMDB wreck
rankings when something is current and
popular right now it's got a skyrocket
in the ratings and then obviously ten
years later it's gonna be a much
different story but it's just that when
something is popular right now it has a
rabid fan base that wanna like this is
the greatest thing ever even though in a
year they're gonna move on to something
else even let alone someone who's just
like a passive fan but yeah that that is
an issue and that's the whole concept of
over rating or overhyping something that
even though if it's good it's good you
do it a disservice almost by setting on
these expectations that people go into
it expecting you know a masterpiece like
I don't know like the greatest anime
I've ever seen or matching their
favorites of all time and then it's just
good but they're like this isn't as good
as you know full mark rahman is pulling
off his Brotherhood so now I'm
conflicted it's like should I be should
I dislike this because everyone else
likes it so much or like what's going on
it's so I really felt like hype can
affect your opinion on our show mm-hmm
it's like I shouldn't matter but it
matters so much yeah I think there's a
lot of people nowadays though just I
don't know they 5 own hype we're never
discussing something like they're a
fangirl or something and they just you
know they start blowing things out of
proportion you know and that's just the
way they're expressing themselves
generally now so it can't get like I
think mistaken a lot of the time it was
over height because you know one person
acts like that another person hears it
you know they enjoyed the show so they
think that's the way to describe the
show and you know it goes on and on
until you got a massive them you know
but yeah can I mention some shows that I
found overrated that have no hype right
now and they're just overrated from what
I see here on YouTube critics basically
sucking them off yes I know you don't
mention recreate errs that's already I
was gonna mention recreate errs it's too
recent I'm talking old school stuff that
everyone loves and everyone says is
perfect and if you say it's not perfect
you're obviously you you can get a Leon
okay if you keep I will flip out I'm not
[ __ ] drilling I'm not saying you're
like chill dude okay and I'm not gonna
say Killa Killa either because I think
that was fairly rated by most youtubers
but I think that serial experiments lain
is the worst anime I've ever watched why
cuz he didn't get it I knew I mean he'll
offense um Danny like that does come
down to you but I wouldn't say it was
like a great great anime it was good
maybe a little bit ahead of its time you
know especially if you were young ya
know if you like if you oh no one who
just came up for [ __ ] Dragon Ball Z
and then you okay I wanna know what you
new anime oh they're super experiments
lain let me watch that it's gonna fly
over your head there is no way you can
jump I just watched it like a year ago I
had to watch three times to understand
it okay
well I don't want to insult your
intelligence or anything but I'm pretty
sure I understood it I had a very
pleasant debate with a bunch of people
about serial experiments lain everyone
seems to like about it is basically that
it was able to predict the Internet and
how it interfaces with humanity in the
future that's what everyone seems to
like about it does anyone have anything
that's cool about serial experiments
lain is that you what different outcomes
than just that that's what's cool about
the series I think we did a video about
it a long time ago I'm not sure like
somebody did a video I was pretty sure
it was Joey I think he was just talking
about good series to watch that mind
[ __ ] eeeh I think that was his video I
think that's actually what it was titled
anime that online [ __ ] you but it's cool
isn't it you can have a different
prediction with serial experiments lain
you know like some people can perceive
that it was her enticing with the
Internet to escape the government you
know people and you know interpretated
that it was her predicting what the
internet was going to do like you know
what you said and like there were so
many other holy cow this is a crappy
show yeah I just I just like the psycho
here's what I'll I'll say this because I
think it applies to also anime like
Evangelion and Ergo Proxy if personally
I enjoyed all of them because but I know
specifically because I'm very interested
and I studied things like philosophy and
politics so for me for example a
Mongolian well I had a lot of issues
with the characters like I really
disliked suji's kind of character and
things that because I couldn't relate to
him but I what I loved about the anime
it really made me think like it explores
these really interesting and important
philosophical concepts which I love so
when a man that makes me think that I
still love it when it references
philosophers I know and stuff like that
even if maybe the characters are
something we're lacking so I will still
enjoy it but I will also understand why
some people who are not that interested
in philosophy don't really that's not
why they watch any before they watch it
more for story or characters or whatever
they they will not necessarily
appreciate it as much so I understand
both sides there all right so that's
lovely and I liked even galleon but I
would definitely not say it was as good
as everyone else seemed to make believe
it is yes definitely worried it
definitely gets over that family gets
all behind I don't like that series of
toe is [ __ ] even Kelly is my favorite
anime of all time
I will not want to ever talk to you but
the thing the thing is what takes the
piss more is then after they tell you oh
no but you got watch the movie you need
to see the end of the night on and then
you really get it I mean you watch dad
it's even worse you're like oh my god
[ __ ] amazing man the end of it one
getting the movie to me that's the only
ending I refuse any endings and it was
amazing I liked the movie The End of
Evangelion I still don't think it was
perfect
but I did like it I thought the end of
the actual series was like disaster no I
think it depends what kind of ending you
want like it depends on your
because for me my philosophy is totally
in line with the end of evangelion and
the message there about society and
individual agency so I was I love the
end of evangelion but I could not bear
an ending to be like the series because
the series is all about something
completely different like the ending is
completely different philosophy so which
is why again why I find it says I I was
blown away in terms of like the
philosophy of the end of evangelion that
ending and stuff I love that so for me
it was really good in that sense but I'm
not saying it is the most relatable
characters I'm not saying that you know
the story itself is the most compelling
story ever but the underlying themes I
really loved and I think certain anime
can definitely be appreciated for stuff
like that now interesting thing I mean
in the chat said that maiden abyss is
overrated
object and Evangelion man I will agree
that Maiden abyss is overrated I'll tell
you why
I watched it I'm knocks kept telling me
it is the best anime of the year and all
this stuff and I liked it I thought it
was very good however there was a
missing piece for me to keep me really
kind of have you know a guttural
reaction like I can't wait to see season
two and that was I felt they needed to
reveal more about the villain and about
the earth nature of the abyss itself why
is it so important to everyone that
they're willing to do all these horrible
things for it like I felt there was a
piece missing to make it perfect to make
me as excited about it as Knox was so
because Knox talked it up so much I was
like this is good this is really good
but it's not what I was expecting
so yeah Knox you ruined everything
alright so I apologize I guess you're
more of a Dragon Ball super guy anyway
so let's not get into is like maiden
abyss which is actually pretty amazing
and definitely the best anime of the
year well what are you having in mind
that's comparable to maiden abyss
I'm not saying it's the best anime of
all time but tell me it happened tire it
season two well was that took home Titan
season two he was more satisfied with
that yeah that was my favorite anime
overall but if you're Tom a new anime
yeah let me your new anime well that
would be
of their man ah so it would probably be
made an abyss and vanishing line from
your most enjoyable news it's becoming a
meme it is not that good I'm gonna watch
it just to argue with you okay it's not
good but but this thing I'm not saying
masterpiece anime I'm just saying it's a
really good action enema I really loved
the story how it sets up a mystery and
then pursues it I love the characters so
yeah it's just like one of those anime
that it's not it's not like I'm like
saying yo this anime in ten years this
anime is gonna be the [ __ ] but when I
watch them I really look forward to
watching cuz I'm like yo this is like a
really fun anime to watch made an abyss
definitely up there for the best new
anime better than say recreator switch a
lot of people really love died I thought
it was okay at best but I think ya know
you know it's up there but I'm just
saying that I I expected like one little
more piece like well something to really
intrigued me like he was building up to
something at the end of the season I'm
like yes okay so give me that thing give
me that one twist it's like what is the
villain really doing but why is he doing
this what is the secret of the abyss
where mother something the mother and
then it's just like it ends it on a damn
it
so close mmm Freddy's I mean I can I
suggest maybe you pick it up if you're
in that much of a hurry to continue the
series yes
hell no I mean I would I would disagree
with your point of recreate as though
just for the simple fact if like me or
like yourself on a Mac we both dropped
the series so it can't write yeah but
you could only get so far I was like wow
and I heard some people drop me even
before that like episode form 5 and
stuff a misty drop in at episode 1 I
didn't think it was amazing either
recreate errs I wouldn't even call it
overrated cuz I think the only people
that actually liked it her mother's
basement and his you know and his mother
know quite a few people I know Chad's
here in
no ranked afraid that quite a few people
did like re-creators
wagon made was overrated dragon made I
agree was overrated this is terrible
everyone's pushing me off it was fun
though I mean it was fun but it was
overrated
yeah and that's the problem someone
mentioned mob cycle 100 in the chat and
again I very much enjoyed mob cycle 100
but before I watch the people were
saying this is so great this is better
than one dropped it I dropped it first
episode I didn't dropped it I liked it
but I didn't like what it wasn't like it
couldn't meet the expectations that
people set up and I don't know if it's
if people just like like to be the
trendsetters so you know like a big
youtuber will make a video saying this
is amazing and then it was like he was
right it's amazing and then they start
like you know building this up and
you're just like then you get oh yeah
it's a little something because one
person describes it like that everyone
starts using the same word and then you
know they will blown out of proportion
up because now the only word to describe
it is it's amazing and then you watch it
any like mad no doesn't think it's like
even if you like it everyone's saying
it's amazing and if you don't think it's
amazing you're like is there something
wrong with me or like what what is
happening with this anime but Briggs you
were complaining in the chat that you're
not talking a lot so say something a
little bit already
Oh Briggs what what do you say that's no
he said nothing Briggs Naruto Naruto
punks as seven deadly sins is overrated
for sure I agree I can't believe how
popular it is like it's so much fun to
watch I very much enjoy it I have no
problem with it but like it's extremely
popular it's like top 10 manga in Japan
for sales is it well I like it we
actually caught five like in like the
last when I checked it's crazy
oh my god and sword art online big luffa
pardon oh yeah I didn't think it'd be
that big that mean
five-oh jag antic I want to find it it
blows my mind how many sales were yet
well the thing is with some deadly sins
its popular but I think it's fine like
it's like it's a fun anime I don't think
people are saying yo seven deadly sins
bro
it's the you know it's the next big
thing it's the next issues there's a lot
of kids in late that like haven't
watched anything else and it's like
their best anime ever it's like the new
sort of line in the sword art online in
the community is it like I didn't even
know though because to me it's just like
a font and him I didn't know it was that
big oh it's pretty like crazy big like
youtubers don't talk about it which I
don't are standing the only reason a
outsells Hunter x Hunter is because
Tolga she is a bum agree with that well
no if hunter hunter is overrated it's
you you are 50% responsible for
overrating it so I don't know how you
could say that I think I said she was
amazing it was one of my favorite anime
of all time it was borderline
how can you say it's overrated because
everyone says it's the perfect anime and
it's nice it is overrated there's
certain arcs that are not good at all
yeah there are parts that are just not
that great the first two arcs of the
series are very average yeah yeah yeah
just as generic is forc in new or one
piece we need to continue this role yeah
like they're like I think it's good
overall and there's certain arcs that
are just like amazing so like I I it's
really good I think it's a little bit
overrated
just cuz I'm knock says it's amazing ten
at a ten by the way a few people just
mentioned Tokyo ghoul in the chat I saw
um I think caster mentioned - yeah I
would agree a hundred percent on Tokyo
ghoul personally because I when I
started watching it I was watching it
together with the girls and
there was so much hype when I started
and you have that awesome freaking
opening right unravel and I'm going into
this I'm like yo this is crazy this is
gonna be crazy
and like I said like six episodes in I
dropped it I was like this is ridiculous
it was just cannibal porn like the
people getting sexual pleasure out of
eating and torturing people it was like
such like an edgy tumblr wannabe anime
like you're you know Twilight style oh
look we're edgy because of the violence
like people always thoroughly read the
manga but you know I understand that
mangas are often better manga are often
better but like I couldn't get through
the anime at all so that's just me I
thought the situation was okay and they
fell off really bad on the second season
yeah yeah the man was definitely Waber
but even with the manga itself we became
overrated with the introduction of Lee
so it's the story itself really to a
certain point because I'm sure still the
author had input on the anime movie or
something I agree with you as far as
Tokyo ghoul being operated in fact I
think it was crazy overrated
unfortunately I think that you way
undersell it because I don't think it's
a terrible anime I just don't think it's
good particularly I didn't say it was
terrible
I just said it's over I'm talking to
anime no I think it's horrible so yeah
it's true but it might be just kind of
like my own personal preference they're
kicking in like with you not loving
killer kill its kind of those like you
know also in the chat a lot of people
just mentioned JoJo's being overrated
that's night you think that ok so
there's an issue with JoJo's okay here's
a major issue the major issue is like
other amazing things like undertale and
Rick and Morty the fan base kind of is
terrible for a lot of JoJo's and there's
a lot of people that
over-talk JoJo's and while I think it's
a great show all in all it
just a crazy fan base but you're the guy
no no god you're talking about yourself
more than Knox talk like you are that
turned it off after the first episode I
thought was the most stupid thing ever
yeah I think only what comes down to you
is people say it's great but they don't
really give an idea of what to expect so
then it's left to right the own person's
idea of what makes a great show and then
when they start watching it they're not
getting what they want and then they're
like this is crap I need the crazy fan
base I think that there an issue with
Joe Joe's but since none of you here
have actually watched Joe Joe's it makes
it a little bit harder to talk about
watched it I've watched it please the
court
what did you watch all four parts Joe
Joe so far that around no I don't want
you fool pose how about since you're the
manga master and you read every manga
ever even if it's garbage like you do
why haven't you Joe John me JoJo's if
I'm aware as garbage I'm not gonna read
it best always free more you you're at
the fairy tale and bleach and you can't
read Joe Joe's yeah okay that one they
were not long
I like how noises every all those points
I chose in real time I love it how many
tell some jokes I definitely appreciate
that
super eyepatch wolf made for 30 minute
videos explaining why Joe Joe's is
amazing
that was nice doing code knows I don't
know super eyepatch wolf definitely but
take somebody to sit down and explain 30
like another two 30 minute videos on why
an anime series is amazing
is it really that amazing I mean pretty
this way put it this way Joe Joe Joe Joe
goes out man
was a weekly shonen so that's it came
out one chapter per week eeeh from 1987
all the way up until 2004 and then in
2004 it changed into a monthly silent
magazine you're welcome my friend once
where every time you're on the toilet
bowl for the next two years you will be
occupied no I'm not gonna sit through
that crap okay when I know it me the
whole story makes no sense it knows you
don't make sense so then I was asked to
go okay restart let's create a new
universe dude you're very wrong because
you have so it doesn't just like
debating it with the wall because now a
new universe no only in part 7
[Laughter]
interesting to have conversations
because even among us all of us being
anime fans we disagree on what is over
in and what isn't and of course people
in the chat disagree stuff so that's the
fun part of it yeah so subjective I want
to just before I forget I want to talk
about Guido quickly about my experience
with sword art online because right now
you know sword art online is widely
hated you know there's only a few people
who are like publicly I love it so a lot
of people like yeah it was ok I don't
think it was as bad as people say and
then a lot of people hate it but for me
when I watched it it was at the height
of the hype like it was being hiked
it was being a hot as one of like the
first anime it was being hiked all over
the place it had the insanely high my
animalist ray ranking right so I went
into it expecting something really good
you know the first season when it got
started I was like yo this is quite good
you know this is interesting really
interesting concept and then of course
as it gets into the second season leave
us stop that's when it falls off and
that's that's a disappointment of it
it's like you're expecting something
good it gives you hope at the beginning
you're like oh [ __ ] you know this is
interesting and then sadly it goes
downhill which is almost like worse than
if it sucked right away you know it like
gives you that tinder hope and then it's
you so that's kind of my problem with
sword art online I know some people
still like it
boruto was mentioned mom King talked
about a little bit and easy legend um
King doesn't think that it's overrated
because most people don't like it I want
to ask you guys about that I haven't
watched boruto yet but we know that
Naruto is huge and ice yeah that is true
like no Marco really is not over over
rated in any way you have Naruto fans
triggered that boruto isn't as good and
then you have the not Naruto fans that
say this is a pretty man anime no one's
really talking it up except for a few
people said that the recent episode like
the recent two episodes are really good
but I haven't seen them yet so do not
know yeah yeah I saw some tweets people
saying like it turns around like
recently it's been amazing yeah I'm a
little skeptical to be honest but I will
I'll check it out I guess that's the
thing I can't trust people's opinions
with Naruto the same way I can't trust
your opinion with Jojo because you have
one I watched the first eight episodes I
think oh wow your cellphone that's the
problem I feel like everyone said oh we
got to watch part two in part three I
can't do it man some kid to get to their
live I watched I watched like up to the
guy who's in the the stone pillar and
you know he escapes foody Wow he hides
in the congratulations
you watched 12 episodes yeah
but I'll say as much as the second
generation protagonist fits the
temperament of the show I was already
done I can't talk about an anime with
people that haven't watched it it's just
it's very it can't help my side of the
situation can we stop talking about Jojo
how we get back into the side I try to
end that now but that was my fault my
cowboy bebop is operated like crazy [ __ ]
off is ovaries okay guys just like just
I have to address something in the chat
someone called law with a freakin little
witch academia Oh said Gurren Lagann is
good but it is definitely if anything
dragon is underrated bro because people
never talk about the philosophical
themes in Gurren Lagann salt i invite
you sir i will link it in the
description and in the chat watch my
video called 5 anime that will change
your life last 10 minutes are all about
going along on why Gurren Lagann changed
my life why it's my favorite animal time
so watch that and then you will see why
I do not think it's overrated if
anything it's underrated because it's
freaking amazing guys amazing Pablo
Bebop please tell me your problem so I
can get triggered and freak out and then
will my problems with Cowboy Bebop
there's just so many I can't even know
where to begin the pacing was terrible
for me I think there was a compelling
plot at all I always think a plot is
important and there really wasn't any in
cowboy bebop you don't think there was a
plot yeah what was the plot what do you
mean you know getting food fighting with
their food did we not did we not just
talk about you guys not like in cliches
so because because Spike doesn't want to
be the Pirate King there's no plot no
wait no no no no no now we still have a
story we still have a point to a story
it doesn't have to be pirate King
whatever whatever but at the end of day
if you're watching something you're
there for story what is presenting to
you so ok actually really agree with
adamak on this cowboy bebop actually had
multiple plots because each character
had within its own stories in its own
plot each person was trying to find
themselves and you know regain not only
a piece of their past but regain who
they were and towards the end of this
like then you wind up to find out that
most of the story cast is
spike and then at the end of it with the
battle with the one dude I forgot his
[ __ ] name
yes yeah and then you realize that that
was the main plot of the story is
rekindling spikes whole entire past
throughout the whole entire series with
also revealing everyone else's past that
in the crew okay so what you're
basically saying is the plot of the
story was that you have four characters
and each of them has a past that they
tackle with over the anime you know I
can tell you you're wrong please dad had
basically no depth our growth throughout
the series and neither did freakin
little ed was his name a girl okay
whatever her name is Francois z-- and
this shows me that you guys didn't even
watch this anime but listen okay so I
mean it's been too long I don't know if
you guys are literary fiction but what
literary fiction does as opposed to
something like you know action based a
romance based is it tries to capture
certain you fundamental aspects of human
life of life so certain fundamental
themes so it doesn't have to be based on
over you know like a plot like a one
quest or goal it's based on humans and
their relationships with each other this
amazingly you see a great character he
has this backstory he's such a chill
like cool character where like there's
depth to him same thing the way the
interactions between them they a jet
spike and on the ship is amazing it's so
genuine it's so cool like I would love
to watch those guys for a hundred two
hundred episodes not I mean it's always
taken like this okay let's take it no
like shameless shameless is a really
really so it's big around ever
where a lot of people are watching it's
one of the like the it's really it's
actually a really good show but there's
no plot to that you know what I mean but
you're watching access aspects of
people's real life you know what I mean
it's the same thing with Cowboy Bebop
there doesn't need to be a plot for it
like set forth this really amazing story
yes so doesn't have a story then because
spikes story from start to finish
yeah but exactly but then that's I'm
saying Sheamus does have a story though
does it adventure in it you seem to be
saying that a plot is the same thing as
a character having one set goal and
running towards that goal I say there's
an issue with the plot you say we'll
stop what peace chasing what peace
that's not what I mean wait the point
spike is that he's had this backstory
and he doesn't know what he wants out of
life he's kind of a drift which is in
many ways which is what a lot of people
are in the world especially in the
modern world full of technology that
alienates us right so it is actually it
has an important message even though he
doesn't have this you know really set
goal he doesn't know if he wants to live
or die like it's it's very very gripping
and for me a lot just cuz it's episodic
doesn't mean it's bad because a lot of
the episodes explore different science
fiction themes and relationships and
things of that so like the virtual
reality episode I loved there's so many
different aspects that explores explores
different genres so different episodes
are named after different genres of
music and then it has that different
sort of feel and vibe there's so much
there okay don't have a plot and it's
shameless just like Seinfeld is a show
that doesn't have a plot so whatever so
when you think of Cowboy Bebop the the
frickin premise of the show is cowboy
bebop okay
that's amazing but as I said Cowboy
Bebop and I like spike as a character
Spike's a great character but no one
else is really even nearly as good
Valentine's not bad and she acts
we did have development over like two
episodes but aside from that jet and
Edie had nothing that was half the cast
spike was everything we were watching
for let's be honest I grew with Knux I
really just watched for Spica Holly was
an amazing character it was character
driven as in like we really only carry
like cared for him but I grew with
adamak me like it was a spike story you
watched like for his development you
know that Masonic and you've stayed a
long time only yeah I mean like you look
amazing dub you stayed along for like
the action but eventually you get to the
point where like you see is developing
with his character like which he wants
to live or diet okay and it was very
interesting but that worked that worked
against it for me because the thing is I
would get a snippet of spike story and
I'll be like wow that's cool then I get
taken out from spike story too then oh
yeah you do one thing and I'm like right
okay then again I get a bit of spike
story I'm like oh I really want to know
more then I get taken out again and it
keeps on doing that so for me it was the
pacing issue like if they at least like
early on gave me that story so I was
like why okay and then we can move on
because the real-world stuff weren't
that interesting when he met that old
woman and he was hoping I like look for
some freakin name tag thing and it was
just like I am NOT interested in this
the girl he liked got killed on a
rooftop and stuff that stuff was
interesting this minor Rob spoiler anime
is only 17 years old man yes I still
haven't seen it okay it is like white
his arm doesn't necessarily have an
overarching plot Charmian Jack mentioned
Clannad could we talk
and move on from a Cowboy Bebop yeah
that's yeah part one is definitely a
very not you're breaking up what Knox
you're breaking up a bit I don't know if
it's you or me whatever but the thing is
yes
several people mention the chat Clannad
and Clannad after story is overrated and
AnoHana is overrated I disagree
completely with both of those however
the thing is you don't know when these
people might have seen them because
maybe I said before before it was so a
lot of hype to it and I was like do I
really love this it surprised me
positively whereas maybe some people saw
it after everyone was hyping it up and
they're like oh we didn't live up to my
expectations because I was expecting the
greatest thing ever
however in my opinion both of those were
masterpieces of the romance genre so I
loved those rates right like a point one
planet also does it when you see both
you mean an Ohana and after story okay
sorry yeah and an Ohana we're good
that I got no complaint about them but
planet part 1 hey you're an opposing
side that it was the most boring market
ever okay I don't want to hear what you
have to say but part two I also think
was overrated even though I liked it I
do think it was definitely overrated I
got into it after the height where
everyone was talking about how it's
basically the best thing ever it'll make
you cry it didn't make me cry because
you know was that a long serious like
was it over 24 hours like 12 episodes
episode it's both seasons 5 plus 25 I
think oh that's nice length the nod is
better than Clannad definitely not it's
definitely not better it's good number
which version though doesn't say what a
sakes
okay okay okay yeah no Canon was good I
liked arrows Waldo I did like hair but
although I was like I was like what the
[ __ ] and then goes and explained his
vision of the ending to me and I was
like oh [ __ ] that's brilliant
but like before that I was like what the
[ __ ] is this and I don't like I don't
like to be the guy that having people
explain anything to me
I wasn't expected I was like damn he's
right that's that's awesome Oh what was
the one what was the one where the girl
God it was a music one and the animation
was really good about the blonde the guy
it was about the pianist the boy who
played that was over hi for me really
really bad when I went into it but I
actually winded up really enjoying it
still with the override so I went over
hiding them oh yeah get me wrong like
the first couple episodes I didn't think
it was that good but once it started
building up you know what I mean I
started really enjoying it but like when
I first went in you know they kind of
like dented my thought you know
expectations and stuff yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like that ever happen to you
guys with any other series
yeah well no most the time I wheat I
don't watch I just read and I don't mix
ooh people much so I enjoyed myself but
not as much as something like an Ohana
or Clannad after story wasn't in the
same league it was good but not so well
that that's just you man so just me
because I'm a human being now look you
not naruto content producing robot
Dragonball boy you'll want to talk okay
I have to go to the washroom by the way
so I'm gonna I'm gonna be right back you
guys continue oh yeah all right and I
said mister you guys nuts what's your
opinion on your name's ending your names
ending oh yeah I liked it
you like that cuz me I loved I loved the
movie the ending kind of pissed me off
and that's why I still think it took a 9
out of 10 like you said but like
everyone likes it's a 10 out of 10 they
loved it that's one anime that's kind of
overhyped for me the ending pissed me
off I don't think I should I get that it
was kind of just like oh yeah I mean
each other like 17,000 years later
actually I don't know how long later it
was but these
oh [ __ ] ending so three so I know what's
your name I mean I think that's the
thing though the thing is really and
truly she should have been Oded in him
way older than him who because I mean
the gal with girl the gelding he was
switching bodies with what that Oh back
to your name if I were in fate somehow
no he said faith stop
I mean feel fantastic that girl was
already like he's aged in it when he was
switching body in it is that I'm between
there were three years apart the three
years so she's four years older than
yeah so okay yeah no like one that I
really watched like four times like the
plot holes weren't too bad it was the
ending for me I thought they could have
done it a lot better it was kind of like
my thoughts for the SAO I still enjoyed
Sao but they had so much potential to be
better I think it was because I thought
look I thought of a been better ending
myself that I couldn't enjoy the ending
anymore I'd hate it when that happens
are you guys how about Jojo again oh
it's possibly one of the greatest enemy
of reason no no man Mark you did this to
yourself my personal experience I
started on part three I didn't realize
there was a 2012 thing and I started
with Stardust Crusaders maybe that's why
I actually continued it as opposed to
other people that's the most like
tension oh who knows though yeah yeah
except it's way better
no all right cool guys cool so so I
think it's about time to start wrapping
things up we've been here about an hour
I think thanks obviously everyone
joining us in the chatter one here in
the stream before we go let me know guys
who you are and what you do one if you
want to throw in some on the overrated
anime they you haven't we haven't talked
about yet you can throw it in
quickly during your outros and obviously
guys if you do enjoy the rank of a you
can join us every week 5 p.m. Eastern
Time on Thursdays and leave a like if
you enjoy it now up to you I'm now I
gotta I do anime news soon animations
and gaming nice that so everyone's link
is in the can check it out there direct
link to their YouTube channels let's go
now to soul mark let's go first do all
day animes soul fix your money yo I am
Briggs from the YouTube channel all day
anime the most already anime for me
based on my experience was attack on
Titan I went in there like the first see
it was the first evening I joined in
around 6 episodes so it was like right
like it was literally the high I've
never been in like a more hype situation
and I just didn't didn't meet my
expectations but anyway on my channel I
talked a lot about the seven deadly sins
I do fact videos explain concepts all
the good stuff you should check me out I
also love the poster on your left by the
way I know it's badass
boom actually I have to say I kind of
see where you're coming from Briggs
because when I saw season 1 of attack on
Titan it was at the height of the height
and when I got to like the middle of the
season I was kind of disappointed with
slow paced I was like why is everyone
freaking out about this but then with
reading the manga and season 2 and stuff
now I'm all like yes it's amazing but I
can see how first time watching it
during the height of the hype just
watching season 1 how you could be
disappointed so you know you're not
crazy you're not even watching it again
it's like slowly paced imagine waiting
week by week to watch it like everyone's
going crazy and I'm like I just wasn't
enjoying it that much season 2 I enjoyed
very much low need to go to you hey can
I talk about attack and Titan or no
during your outro go ahead you talk
about Naruto Naruto accessories only
anyway so I'm next a coop I have a
youtube channel here on YouTube and they
talk about analyses I
front of popular anime and I do not know
now which is sort of said it anyway
so don't worry it's not only Naruto not
only but so overrated anime I briefly
mentioned face a night unlimited blade
works I think that was crazy overrated
so that's not what I will be talking
about now since I already mentioned it
but for an anime no one talked about I
think the ending of Soul Eater
was one of the worst endings in anime
history well but I went over it I mean
everyone agreed to them no there are a
lot of people that praise the hell out
of Soul Eater
I think the whole anime was overrated
but the ending was just abysmal I
personally have no problem with us I'm
innocent brain blade works other than I
was like I said unlimited breathe works
blade thing is that that amia is kind of
a douche in many cases and not all find
out for me but I mean that's him all the
time so that was just looking dude what
about the bad guys tell me one bad guy
Oh Shinji Shinji was the bait bag I do
is it badass right or kira-kira remember
how PA died no spoilers but remember how
Kili died I was kind of his fault cuz
he's a but please know what ya know I
didn't ever probably yeah Shinji was
annoying as [ __ ] but he got what it was
yeah yeah yeah there were no good guys
it was just messing with you
the media arc and good no that's just
[ __ ] hot man
Diaz was good yes waifu in that show
yeah oily yeah I mean okay soul to you
sir to me yeah I'm so maka
you guys should know me by now
and yeah JoJo's is is overrated crap do
you know what [ __ ] if you try and read
it just so you know there's a hundred
and twenty-one volumes so far and keep
in mind the one piece only has a
t9 okay there you go one piece is
underrated under it it needs to be way
longer than it already is guys yeah
thank you all for joining me by the way
z-9 says his or her birthday's on
January 1st so happy early birthday
that's gonna be a fun we're New Year
celebration and yeah thanks
Gnawa Knox almond Briggs and soul for
joining me this was a fun discussion a
lot of people in the chair very invest
and a lot of us got triggered because we
have different opinions but that does
make for the best types of discussion so
yeah thank you guys it was fun
definitely looking forward to next week
I don't know what the topic is well
we'll keep you posted if you want to
stay in touch with us and know what you
know about all this type of stuff follow
us on the social medias and all that
stuff and until next time everybody
see ya space cowboys and that is not an
underrated state that is not an
overrated statement guys watch Canadian
rules [ __ ] you all